hey brady i am matt henderson i like
making mathematical animations and i
wanted to show a few that relate to the
patterns of orbits in the solar system
the first one is the inner planets and
so this is the approximate pattern that
the inner planets trace out obviously
things aren't to scale we've got the sun
we've got mercury venus earth and mars
going around in their approximate orbits
and relative speeds they're spinning
around the sun is at the center and now
we're to actually move so we're
following earth and we're interested in
what are the patterns are traced out by
the other planets from kind of like from
the perspective of earth we start to see
some interesting patterns
[Music]
the pattern from venus is starting to be
quite regular
[Music]
we'll start to see this kind of
five-pointed shape
you can see we've got one of the points
here we've got two three and the next
time venus comes around it completes
this five points one two three four five
and that's because the ratio of the
orbits between venus and earth are is in
an 8 to 13 ratio so the difference there
is accounting for the five-fold symmetry
in general it's just like a pretty
pattern
i think these are called epicycloids
they're kind of like the spirograph
patterns that you get on rolling circles
around circles
and those just happen to be the ones
that the planets trees like
now let's look at this asteroid crania
that has been referred to as earth's
second moon but that's just
sensationalist kind of thing and it is
what it is is an asteroid that's in
orbital resonance with the earth
which mean in this case it means that
its year is the same as earth's year
but it's not orbiting earth it's also
orbiting the sun but in a more kind of
elliptical orbit so if we mistakenly
thought it was orbiting orbiting the
earth then what would its orbit look
like it wouldn't be a circle it'd be
some kind of
mix of circles and ellipses or something
so let's see
so again we start out with the sun at
the center
earth is orbiting and then this is quina
this little asteroid that is orbiting
with the same year
now we've shifted to the perspective of
the earth and the path that queenia is
tracing out is this kind of kidney bean
shape again this these aren't the exact
correct orbits but it's roughly
kind of like what's going on so we don't
see an elliptical orbit if we were wrong
and we thought earth was the center of
the solar system then with karina would
be the sort of weird second moon tiny
asteroid guy that is orbiting us in this
kind of kidney bean shape that would
take some explaining if you believe that
the earth was at the center of
everything yeah that's a kind of
complicated behavior to explain
but i suppose it's just built up of a
circle and an ellipse kind of added
together so maybe as soon as you saw
that you might invent that explanation
you put these on twitter but what have
you done in the past yeah i used to run
this blog on tumblr that where i posted
mathematical gifs and
back then um i don't think they were
quite as good as my new ones i think
sort of progressed a little bit um so
for example you know this was the new
crania animation this is the old one
here it's explaining the same
shape but it takes a little bit longer
to see exactly what's happening possibly
because you don't have that shift in
perspective you know where you establish
the orbits with the sun at the center
and then you shift to this following
earth because earth is stationary
you can kind of see what's going on
right
some story should be too in that one
yeah the sun is stationary as well so if
we look at the new one the sun is also
still stationary right but the fact that
the sun is at the center of the old one
is maybe a bit confusing as well here
i've just put earth is the center to
emphasize that we're doing sort of
geocentric thing and both i've done the
trick of having like stars in the
background which are just randomly
generated points but the stars that are
so swing around i think helps to show
you're in a sort of weird reference
frame that's rotating with the earth and
then you've got another old one too from
there yeah related to this ratio of
venus and the earth that this one here
which is you have venus going around
you've got earth going around and you
just draw a line between the two it's a
bit different to tracing the relative
path but you get a similar shape you get
that five-pointed shape that i pointed
out before it's fun stuff with those
planets isn't it yeah and i mean for me
it's kind of just a way to talk about
the spirograph patterns epicycloids and
that you get from circles rotating
around um it's just kind of fun to plug
in the numbers that roughly correspond
to like venus and earth for example and
of course it's not exactly 8 to 13 ratio
but it gives the 5 pointed symmetry
because 8 plus 5 is 13.
[Music]
today's episode has been brought to you
by brilliant now we often focus on all
their great math courses like these ones
but it seems appropriate today to let
you know they happen to have this epic
course on gravitational physics as you
can see it's
packed with stuff relating to today's
video
but going much much deeper of course
brilliant is fun it's engaging it's
educational of course but most
importantly it's really interactive why
not visit today and see what a great
resource they've created
maybe sign up if it's for you or give a
subscription as a gift to that person
who already has everything
there's 20 off a premium subscription by
going to brilliant.org
number file the address on the screen
thanks brilliant for supporting today's
episode
you